on this jackass you decided to do the
bull stunt again yes and we have a
picture
well i was trying to do a magic trick in
front of the bull and i don't know if
the bull hated magic or hated my
execution of magic
but whatever it was it worked out really
good for footage and not so great for me
yeah i had a broken wrist this broken
rib concussion brain hemorrhage spent
the weekend in the hospital and it took
me a few months to recover from it but
yeah i know i i that was my last moment
with the bull i believe my neurologist
insisted upon it uh you know i've had a
number of concussions and i'm a little
older now and i don't feel like i have
anything else to prove and i have kids
and i want to kind of be
be there when they get older so i i
don't want to deviate from the fact that
also like this is an emotional journey
for you and i i loved researching about
your dad
and something i didn't know
is that he is the origin story of this
for you
yes my dad um
he had he had a tire company
but
he really only had the tire company i
think so he could prank his employees
he was constantly breaking his employees
and
he would he would do little things
around the house too like
dad would always want to wake me up in
the morning and sometimes i would just
get a glass of water in the face
and i would like what and then he would
start telling me jokes as soon as i woke
up and i thought it was hilarious
because he was so excited for me to wake
up but uh he would like i was in the
shower he poured ice water over the top
he was constantly doing things like that
and
i remember my dad passed in 2018 and i
just been with him in tennessee in the
hospital and i flew home
and
my sister's called said you need to come
back dad is taking a turn for the worst
and i did and i got to the hospital and
my sister was outside
she told me uh dad had passed and it
made me really i mean it devastated me
but at that
obviously uh but at that time i
hadn't told anyone i was doing another
jackass or wanted to and i wanted to get
there in time to tell him that i was
because he loved it so much
right
and i thought that would make him feel
better i never got to tell him that but
i mean he was so proud just when someone
would deliver a pizza to the house he'd
open the door and go home with johnny
knoxville
and he he was selling used like after he
retired from the tire company he was
selling used cars and
on this car it's like dad of johnny
knoxville you know
then he's definitely up there giggling
and cheering you on with the world's
biggest pom-poms and i mean pj johnny
that is what you have done your risk
reward paid off you got to make
something that changed like the
zeitgeist in the culture oh wow thank
you i
well there is
every fluid in the world in in this in
this film
and i thought of
our stands for stain segment
just at dinner last night
i and i need help getting these stains
out because i only have one pair of
pants and i'm leaving for london
tomorrow will you do a stands for stains
i would love to
[Music]